le bois est mouillé là comme par
hasard comme par hasard on attrape une
grosse tourista la télévision tous
ensemble comme par hasard et comme par
hasard un labo va développer un vaccin
comme par hasard qui va tous nous
soigner parce qu'on va tous le prendre
comme par hasard allez goûte voilà
ah ouais c'est très très bon comme par
hasard Annick
Hervé vous serez ensemble je
peux pas vivre c'est pas possible comme
par hasard qui me dit que vous avez pas
mis du Seigneur dedans moi je voulais
dire comme par hasard comme par hasard
ils ont fait dire ton frère un challenge
maintenant comme par hasard oui comme
par hasard pour qu'ils ont fait venir à
ton avis ah pour m'humilier du coup
c'est un un humiliateur
quand les gens se réunissent une réunion
avec des juifs avec des un complot
comment tu as deviné